leah you're hitting these beautiful
notes that no one else is hitting it's
phenomenal i feel like you're the shaky
girl anymore super impressed
kimmy i think these songs were hard for
you you didn't know them i think they
were a mouthful of words but i think you
had some really good moments so i do
have a part for you in the song
obviously kion brook you will have spots
on the song too yes all right tiny t i
don't feel like you put a lot of effort
into this
you didn't give me anything that was
super memorable or super special and
you're too special of a kid to do that
jess
i'm sorry can i say something of course
honestly tiny was not busy with
something else we really really work on
a song at night and whole day until
coming here she said i want to show
jason jojo that she can do this way also
i understand that and i understand that
the calm is special for you
out of the box for you
but for me it was too simple
in the real world every girl is not
gonna have a solo or a featured moment
in every song and sometimes how you
handle yourself when you're not featured
speaks volumes tiny still needs to be a
team player she needs to sing the group
parts and she needs to do good in those
so let's rehearse for a little bit yeah
moms you can go live your best lives out
there
hi mom all right so
let's go over the top
okay
come with me
[Music]
diana i have to commend you because i
can tell that tiny was really really
trying
like i felt that as a mom like i was
kind of
she's confused yeah because she worked
really hard
[Music]
these kids have to prove to her that she
can't live without any of them
and that's the most important thing
right
and so you have to take every
opportunity to do that
that's the best i've ever heard you've
seen kyle and you can even step a little
forward on your part yes all right
hey
[Music]
okay
when i normally don't give you hugs but
i'm giving you one
you okay
i don't know like kinley has a smaller
part than i thought she did like she
sings like a little piece of it
i think my kid killed
her audition
and i'm scared and i just wanted to be
in this group come here let me just
tracy and angie when their kids not
getting apart they're like
boom
i don't think it
[Music]
don't want to helps through that
experience where we're at the bottom
and i just no it's disappointing it
sucks
if they haven't pick a bottom two like i
knew this was gonna happen and i'm gonna
have to live through that diana tiny
doesn't even have she doesn't even have
any part right now the way that you're
handling it big difference
i think you guys should all walk up on
and i think to myself and then everyone
does what a wonderful and you can switch
over a little bit
everything is a test
you have to keep it together it's just a
few more days i think that this is new
with tracy it's not
the kinley show that they're used to
right yeah they're used to kinley like
being number one hey guys we've got a
new weekly show every thursday on the e
news channel featuring celebrities
revealing their favorite and funniest
dms be sure to check out this week's
episode of down in the dms featuring
bretman rock so click here and check out
the whole playlist now